P.M. ON THE EAST.
BUCKLE UP THE.
THE DEMOCRATIC MOB IS OUT OF
CONTROL.
IT'S A PSYCHOTIC STATE OF
DENIAL.
THIS IS THE TRUTH AND REALITY
THAT THE DEMOCRATS IN WASHINGTON
AND THE MEDIA MOB CAN'T COME TO
GRIPS WITH THE REALITY, THE
TRUTH THAT WILL SET THEM FREE.
THEY ARE IN A PSYCHOTIC RAGE AND
IT KEEPS SPINNING OVER AND OVER
IN THEIR LITTLE LIBERAL BRAINS.
EVERY SINGLE THING -- I WILL SAY
IT TONIGHT -- YOU WILL HEAR FROM
THIS DAY FORWARD ABOUT MUELLER,
RUSSIA AND COLLUSION AND
OBSTRUCTION AND TRUMP IS FOREVER
MEANINGLESS AND JUST A LOT OF
NOISE BY BITTER PEOPLE.
FOUR SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS
CONCLUDED NO TRUMP CAMPAIGN, NO
TRUMP RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
THE FBI'S 9 MONTH INVESTIGATION,
NOTHING!
THE HOUSE INTEL INVESTIGATION,
THE BIPARTISAN SENATE
INVESTIGATION, NOTHING.
AND SPECIAL ROBERT MUELLER'S
WITCH HUNT FOUND NOTHING.
THEY WERE TRYING.
MUELLER IS DONE.
IT'S OVER.
THIS IS WORSE FOR THEM AN
SELECTION NIGHT 2016 ESPECIALLY
WHEN THE EXIT POLLS SHOWED
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T WIN ANOTHER
STATE LIKE IN 2004 THAT JOHN
KERRY WAS THE NEXT PRESIDENT.
WRONG AGAIN.
LOOK AT THE TEARS AND UNHINGED
NATURE OF EVERYBODY.
TONIGHT, WE CONTINUE THE
HYSTERIA.
AND THIS IS NOW OFFICIALLY A
MASS MENTAL DISTURBANCE NEVER
BEFORE SEEN ON THIS LEVEL.
FULL-BLOWN PSYCHOTIC MELTDOWN.
THE RAGE TRUMP'S MOB NEW
FAVORITE TARGET, THEY HAVE TO
BLAME SOMEBODY FOR THEMSELVES
ABOUT THE LIES THEY TOLD AND THE
CONSPIRACIES AND THE LIES THEY
SPREAD.
LISTEN CLOSELY TO THIS:
UNDER FEDERAL LAW THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BARR WAS NOT REQUIRED AT
ALL TO RELEASE ANY PORTION OF
THE MUELLER REPORT.
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO RELEASE ONE
WORD.
BUT IN AN EFFORT TO BE
TRANSPARENT, HE DID IT ANYWAY.
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO.
THE AG RELEASED THE REPORT AFTER
REDACTING THAT WAS LEGALLY
REQUIRED INCLUDING THE GRAND
JURY INVESTIGATION.
BARR SUBMITTED A REPORT WITH THE
KEY FINDINGS.
NO COLLUSION AND OBSTRUCTION.
THEY CONCURRED THERE WAS NO
OBSTRUCTION.
MUELLER SPEAK NOW OR FOREVER
HOLD YOUR PIECE.
MUELLER ADMITTED BARR'S SUMMARY
WAS IN NO WAY INACCURATE OR
MISLEADING.
ME AND MUELLER HAVE SOMETHING IN
COMMON.
WE SEE THE MEDIA MOB FOR WHO
THEY ARE.
BARR TESTIFIED BEFORE THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BUT REFUSED
TO INTERROGATED IN THE HOUSE NOT
BY THE CONGRESSMEN AND WOMEN
ELECTED TO OFFICE BUT BY LAWYERS
AND STAFF.
THAT HAS NEVER HAPPENED IN THE
206 YEARS OF HISTORY AND BARR
WAS NOT GOING TO LET IT HAPPEN
NOW.
HE IS STILL WILLING TO TESTIFY
BEFORE ACTUAL COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I THINK THEY ARE AFRAID OF THEM.
BARR TOLD THE TRUTH.
HE COMMITTED NO CRIMES.
LAUGHABLY BECAUSE OF WHAT I JUST
OUTLINED FOR ALL OF YOU, THE
LIST OF PROMINENT DEMOCRATS ARE
CALLING FOR BARR TO BE IMPEACHED
INCLUDING CRAZY UNCLE JOE BIDEN,
ELIZABETH WARREN AND MAXINE
WATERS.
SPEAKER PELOSI SAID BARR LIED TO
CONGRESS.
NO, HE DIDN'T.
CHICKEN LITTLE HIMSELF CONGRESS
COHEN IS CALLING FOR BARR TO BE
LOCKED UP.
THEY LOST IT.
THEY ARE UNHINGED.
LOOK.
>> DO YOU SUPPORT THE IDEA
PUTTING HIM -- JUST HAVING HIM
SIT FOR A HEARING OR LOCKING HIM
UP SOMEHOW?
>> YOU HAVE TO HAVE HIM SIT FOR
A HEARING AND LOCKED UP UNLESS
HE AGREES TO PARTICIPATE AND
COME TO THE HEARING.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT YOUR
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO ORDER THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES TO BE ARRESTED BY THE
SERGEANT OF ARMS AND PUT IN
JAIL?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE WILL DO.
BUT WE CAN'T JUST GO TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
>> Sean: THEY LOST THEIR MIND.
THE DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN
WANTED TO HAND CUFF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE UNITED STATES AND
HAVE THE SERGEANT OF ARMS DRAG
HIM BEFORE THE COMMITTEE OR TO
PRISON.
NO CHARGES.
NOTHING.
WELCOME TO SADDAM HUSSEIN'S USA.
KEEP IN MIND AS WE HAVE BEEN
PREDICTED, THE MOB'S REAL GOAL
IS TO THE IMPEACHMENT OF THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY DON'T LET THE TRUTH OR
FACTS IN ANY WAY GET INTO THEIR
CONSPIRACY THEORYS ON COLLUSION.
TAKE A LOOK.
TWO TOP DEMOCRATS AND WHAT THEY
SAID OVER THE WEEKEND.
THEY LOST IT.
LOOK.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT
IMPEACHMENT TALK MAY HELP THE
PRESIDENT'S REELECTION?
>> I AM CONCERNED IF WE DON'T
IMPEACH THIS PRESIDENT HE WILL
BE GET REELECTED.
>> YOU THINK THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SHOULD OPEN
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS?
>> I DO THINK THEY SHOULD BEGIN
THE PROCESS.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN GREEN, GIVE
HIM CREDIT.
AN HONOR DEMOCRAT.
IT'S ALL ABOUT POLITICS.
THEY WANT TO IMPEACH PRESIDENT
TRUMP BECAUSE THEY CAN'T BEAT
TRUMP IN 2020 AND THEY KNOW IT.
IT'S THE ONLY WAY TO GET RID OF
HIM.
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS ARE
CALLING FOR MUELLER TO TESTIFY
TO KEEP THE COLLUSION HOAX GOING
FOR AS LONG AS POSSIBLE.
LET'S MILK IS DRY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT MUELLER
WOULD SAY.
MAYBE MUELLER WOULD LOVE TO TAKE
ANOTHER PARTING SHOT AT TRUMP
AND THE ADMINISTRATION AND GET
ANOTHER DIG IN.
HE STILL GETS INVITED TO THE
GOOD D.C. ESTABLISHMENT PARTIES.
IT DOESN'T MATTER LEGALLY.
THE DECISION BY BARR IS DONE AND
FINISHED.
THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING WHY LET
MUELLER TESTIFY?
HE WORKS FOR BARR.
THE INNOCENT SMEARING OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
THIS GETS SERIOUS.
THIS HAS TO STOP.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND YOU ARE SUFFERING FROM
THIS PSYCHOTIC RAGE AGAINST HIM,
GO TRY TO BEAT HIM AT THE BALLOT
BOX AND GOOD LUCK WITH THAT.
CRAZY UNCLE JOE, GOOD LUCK.
IF MUELLER TESTIFIES, HE SHOULD
BE FORCED TO ANSWER SIGNIFICANT
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS 2 YEAR, $30
MILLION PERSECUTION.
WHY DID HE THINK IT WAS OKAY TO
HIRE A TEAM OF BIASSED
DEMOCRATIC DONORS TO INVESTIGATE
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND HIRE
HILLARY CLINTON'S FORMER LAWYER
AND HIRE THE PIT BULL WANTED TO
CELEBRATE AT HILLARY CLINTON'S
VICTORY PARTY BUT IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION WAS NO
EVIDENCE IT DID NOT HAPPEN.
DID HE CONCEAL THAT FACT FROM
THE PRESIDENT?
WHY DIDN'T HE TELL THE COUNTRY?
THAT'S A PERJURY TRAP ON
OBSTRUCTION.
IF MUELLER'S MANDATE WAS BROAD
ENOUGH TO INVESTIGATE TAXI CAPS
AND TAX VIOLATIONS, WHY WOULD IT
NOT HAVE BEEN BROAD ENOUGH
INVESTIGATE HILLARY CLINTON'S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DIRTY
RUSSIAN COLLUSION CREATED BY A
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE OFFICER SPY
FULL OF RUSSIAN LINES AND THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" ADMITTED THAT
THE HILLARY CLINTON'S DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER COULD HAVE BEEN
CAMPAIGN CHAOS CREATION FROM THE
START.
WHAT ABOUT SPYING?
DID MUELLER INVESTIGATE THE FACT
THAT MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WERE SPIED ON?
HOW MANY SPIES WERE INVOLVED?
TANKS TO TWO YEARS OF
REPORTING -- THANKS FOR CATCHING
UP.
YOU ARE SLOW ON THE UP TAKE BUT
YOU WERE PUSHING LIES FOR TWO
YEARS.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
PAPADOPOULOS WAS SPIED UPON AND
A BLONDE BOMBSHELL SENT BY OUR
OWN GOVERNMENT WHO WAS FLIRTING
WITH HIM AND USING HER CHARMS.
THAT HAPPENED.
RIGHT OUT OF A BOND MOTIVE.
ON FRIDAY THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
WHO BROKE THE STORE HAD THIS
STUNNING ADMISSION.
--
>> WAS SHE A RUSSIAN AGENT?
>> A GOVERNMENT AGENT.
>> Sean: PAPADOPOULOS SAID
EVERYTHING WAS TRUE BUT WAS THAT
PERSON AN FBI EMPLOYEE?
HOW MANY SPIES WERE USED AND
WHAT ABOUT BIDEN AND OBAMA KNOW?
DID THEY BYPASS AMERICAN LAWS
AND OUTSOURCE ILLEGAL SPYING ON
THE U.S. CITIZENS?
DID THEY OUTSOURCE THAT WHICH
THEY KNEW WERE FRIENDLY
COUNTRIES TO DO THE JOBS THEY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO DO?
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
INVESTIGATING THIS SPYING AND
SOONER WE WILL HAVE THE ANSWERS
WE LOVE AND THE RESULTS OF
HOROWITZ'S INVESTIGATION INTO
FISA ABUSE AND HUBER'S
INVESTIGATION TO ALL OF THE
LEAKS.
MORE UNEARTHED TEXTS FROM THE
LOVEBIRDS PAGE AND STRZOK
SUGGESTING THEY WERE LEAKING
SENSITIVE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION JUST AFTER
THE ELECTION:
IN AN E-MAIL STRZOK WROTE I
THINK THE AGENCY GOT INFO
EARLIER AND HASN'T SHARED IT
WITH US.
THAT MIGHT EXPLAIN ALL OF THESE
INCORRECT LEADS THE MEDIA FOLKS
HAVE AND HIGHLIGHT THE AGENCY
THAT IS THE SOURCE OF THE LEAKS.
THERE WERE CONCERNS THE LEAKS
WERE COMING FROM THE NATIONAL
SECURITY AGENCY OR THE CIA UNDER
OBAMA AND BIND'S WATCH.
-- BIDEN'S WATCH.
LED BY CLAPPER AND BRENNAN.
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS ARE CALLING
FOR A NEW INVESTIGATION INTO ALL
OF THESE LEAKS.
THAT'S ONLY A SMALL PORTION WHAT
HAVE WE WILL BE GETTING.
WE ARE NOT STOPPING.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DEMAND,
TRUTH, AND JUSTICE.
THE RULE OF OUR LES
THE RULE OF OUR LS  -- LAWS AND
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC IS
AT STAKE.
THE MEDIA IS TRYING TO IGNORE
THE ECONOMY, IT'S BOOMING LIKE
WE HAVEN'T SEEN IN OVER 50 TO 60
YEARS.
1.3-MILLION MORE JOBS OPENING IN
AMERICAN THAN JOBLESS
INDIVIDUALS.
UNEMPLOYMENT AT A 49 YEAR LOW.
IN PENNSYLVANIA THEY ARE SO
DESPERATE FOR WORKERS THEY ARE
HAVING JOB SEMINARS IN PRISON.
WHEN ARE YOU GETTING OUT?
WE NEED TO HIRE YOU.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
THOSE WITH A HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE.
EVEN THOSE WHO DROPPED OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL.
RECORD NUMBERS OF UNEMPLOYMENT
FOR WOMEN, AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC AMERICANS AND YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT.
ON FRIDAY TO EXPLAIN THE GREAT
ECONOMIC RECOVERY, YOU HAVE
MSNBC CHRIS HAYES TAKING TO
TWITTER TO ISSUE NEW SUPERIOR
THREOS ABOUT THAT WERE OUT TO
GET OBAMA AND CONSPIREED TO MAKE
THE ECONOMY BAD UNDER OBAMA'S
PRESIDENCY.
-- AND NOW WORKING HARD TO MAKE
THE ECONOMY GOOD.
DIDN'T HAVE TO DO WITH THE TAX
CUTS OR THE BETTER BUSINESS
CONDITIONS.
THE LIMITED GOVERNMENT AND LOW
TAXES PHILOSOPHY OF KENNEDY,
REAGAN AND NOW WORKING FOR
TRUMP.
AMERICANS ARE TUNING OUT THE
CONSPIRACY THREORISTS ON MSNBC